sister love barack and michelle obama's
daughters keep a pretty low profile
but now malia and sasha are opening up
in a rare interview about their famous
mama
in a nutshell they're crazy freaking
proud of her
the former first daughters appear in
becoming a netflix documentary about
their mom's life
and work i'm excited for her to
be proud of what she's done because i
think that's the most important thing
for a human to do is to be proud of
themselves no longer facing that same
scrutiny
being able to let all of that leave your
mind
creates so much more space all the feels
and it gets even better before the girls
said all that about their mom
malia was filmed chatting with michelle
after one of the stops on her sold-out
arena book tour for her memoir which is
also titled becoming
hey little potato oh hi
[Music]
but this is demonstrated in a way it's
just like damn those eight years weren't
for nothing
yeah you know those eight years she's
talking about
that would be her dad barack obama's
time as president
in the white house you see that huge
crowd out there
and that last that you know that last
kind of speech you gave about just like
people are here because people really
believe in love and hope in other people
and also every time you guys play stevie
wonder i don't know i cry a little bit
oh same
back in 2016 when president obama was
still in office
michelle opened up to e.t about how she
and her hubby
tried to keep malia and sasha's lives as
normal as possible
but they made one special exception
i realized because we generally just
don't include the girls
we've tried to normalize their lives as
much as possible so a lot of the stuff
we do
they're like regular kids they're
running in the opposite direction of
what we do
they're not here now they're running
they're trying to hang with their
friends
but i realized that they hadn't been to
a state dinner
now all these years they had never been
to a state dinner
so i thought you know when they look
back on this time when they are talking
to their kids and they're like mom did
you ever go to a steak dinner and they'd
say no
i would feel pretty bad about that so we
thought we're gonna
invite them to one and they got to do
the
uh you know big girl dress-up thing and
let me remind you
they looked super on point nice going
mrs
o 21 year old malia is currently
enrolled at harvard university
while a source previously told et that
18 year old sasha began her studies at
the university of michigan last fall
go blue eti spoke to the director of
becoming nadia hallgren on tuesday
and she said nothing was off limits
during filming
you really get to see the intimacy that
is
is in the film i'm riding with her in
her motorcade you know we're backstage
with the shows
and all these you know there's moments
when she's with her husband
and i was i was pretty much right there
and she opened up about what it was like
to work with the former first lady
having an opportunity to work with mrs
obama on this project
was you know it was just such a joy uh
getting to spend up close and personal
time with mrs obama as well as
her family and all the folks that you
know work with her
you know we we had a lot of laughs it
was it was a very cool experience